all right for decades now we've heard
this refrain go to college that's the
only way to be successful well that's if
you listen to the Elites at least but
that's changing now a new survey by
Thumbtack revealing that 82 percent of
young people reported that they're being
told going to college is the only way to
be successful in life but a third said
their High School didn't have a shop
class but a surprising amount of them
said that they respect skilled trades as
a career 73 percent and now 47 percent
are interested in pursuing a career that
is based on a trade
joining me now Mike Row host of how
America works on Fox Business he's also
the CEO of the micro Works Foundation
Mike the survey also found that there's
a shortage no surprise to any of us who
are ever ever tried to hire somebody but
a shortage of trade Talent
um applications for some of these
technical jobs down by 49 in 2022
compared to 2020
so how is this going to get fixed
slowly I've we've been at it for 15
years micro work started on Labor Day 15
years ago happy birthday to us
um we've been basically singing the same
song which is look the the percentage of
people who leave the workforce every
year uh they're all over 55 right and
it's for every five who leave basically
two come in that's some bad math it's
been going on a long time and the
chickens are coming home to roost right
now we've got acute shortages like we've
never seen before on the other hand we
are moving the needle and we're starting
to see this generation reacting very
differently to some of the questions
that they've been uh asked over the
years vis-a-vis college versus a skilled
trade that is encouraging but this is a
long slow burn Laura it's going to take
a long time to undo the damage we caused
when we took shop class out of high
schools stigmas it's stereotypes it's
myths misperceptions they're slowly
starting to erode but we just have to
keep pushing it
well Mike gen Z is actually factoring in
smartly job security when they're
thinking about a career choice a new
survey showing that 74 of young adults
think skilled trade jobs will not be
replaced by AI artificial intelligence
Mike are these jobs more AI proof than
let's say you know being an associate at
a law firm where your chances of
becoming partner are very small or any
of these other you know web design or
Graphics design jobs that are all their
age as well
I think so I think it's it's tempting to
paint with a broad brush and we probably
shouldn't Robotics and Tech have had an
impact on trade jobs AI is going to have
I think a very similar impact on White
Collar jobs it's it's all going to
affect all of it to a degree but
everybody you just had up there on that
videotape was a scholarship recipient
from my Foundation they're all working
in the trades they have a level of job
security Now that frankly is the Envy of
a big chunk of the workforce because to
your point you're not going to AI out a
plumber or an HVAC person or an
electrician or any of that right so look
we we offer work ethics scholarships
we've got a million dollars up for grabs
right now as we speak we do this twice a
year and um anybody who wants to explore
these careers there are a lot of
different ways to do it but we've been
trying to help people who want to help
themselves in this area than sharing
their stories with the masses and look
I'm not going to take a Victory lap but
it's working it's it's a long slow slog
but we're getting there now Mike some
parents are encouraging their teens
uh their teen kids not to work watch
I have a 15 year old son and he's at
that age where like everyone's getting
jobs and I was like I don't want you to
get a job you do that your entire life
why is that now I just think it's insane
to tell a small child who's like 14 that
they should go out in the world and get
a job for experience we live for like a
million years these days
wait he's not gonna retire until he's
like a hundred
yeah let's raise kids to sit home in
their pajamas you know playing uh video
games with each other I mean I don't
understand that at all my son loved his
job this he's 15 my son loved his job
working at a marina this summer and he I
don't think I've ever seen him seen him
happier
so look I mean that far be it for me to
tell anybody how to parent but rather
than make work the enemy rather than
point to labor and say that's the reason
you're going to be miserable you're
going to spend the rest of your life
making little rocks out of big rocks
find a way to make it cool find a way to
make it fun that's what dirty jobs did
for 20 years that's what we try and do
every day if if we look at work is the
proximate cause of our pain and
suffering then there's no way we're ever
going to be able to spin it into
anything good or worthwhile that woman
right there 150 000 a year welding her
name's Chloe Hudson he's killing it and
she's one of many
well Mike I I think selling every job is
really fun I mean not every job is fun
but it's it's work and you know my
mother used to always say you know most
of life is work
and then there's everything else but
it's it's like it's your attitude I mean
sometimes it's not going to be fun but
that's okay no you'll find good moments
in it
that's a Band of Brothers
yeah well look opinions I'm having a
pretty good day with mine right now you
look like you're having a pretty good
time yeah but whatever job satisfaction
is less about the job and more about the
jobber and that's not a popular
perception but it's the truth
mike always so great to talk to you and
thank you for what you're doing with
your foundation it's fantastic hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else